I'm exhausted and probably you are too
last year was one Trump headline after
another but hang on his presidency is
not all doom and gloom
here are five positive things that have
come out of one year of president
shopping
hoodies grab back President Trump isn't
exactly known as an advocate for women's
right she's a slob she talks like like a
truck driver
of course she have a fat ass absolutely
hey when you're a star they let you do
it you can do anything whatever you want
here's what Trump managed to do to women
in just one year he undermined women's
access to birth control proposed
millions and cuts to teen pregnancy
prevention and made it harder to fight
for fair wages and a safe workplace but
women aren't having it
one day after trans inauguration they
brought around five million people into
the streets across the United States to
promote women's rights it was the
largest single day of protest in US
history
and since Trump took office woman has
been getting more political in much
America a Gupta trans Democratic woman
to run for office has seen an 87%
increase in applications plus Trump may
have tried to cut public funding from
Planned Parenthood but since the
election the NGO has received 400,000
private donations to continue providing
women with health care
Trampas called global warming a hoax
he's boosted coal approved controversial
pipelines and drilling on federal land
and most notably he announces intention
to take the u.s. out of the historic
Paris climate agreement but people
around the world are pushing back big
time in the u.s. counter states cities
businesses and citizens have banded
together they've pledged to uphold the
Paris agreement even if trampled and the
world is doubling down on climate
protection since Trump's announcement 25
more countries ratified the treaty
further strengthening the world's
commitment Trump's number one enemy us
the news media which he has been bashing
since he's announced his run for
president the media is is really the
word I think one of the greatest of all
terms I've come up with is fake Trump
has even suggested that he'd like to
open up the country's libel laws to make
it easier to sue journalists for the
formation but somehow Tom actually
managed to help the journalism industry
with his behavior now newspaper
subscriptions are on the rise the
failing New York Times as Trump calls it
gained more than 130,000 new
subscriptions in just three weeks after
the election when Trump slammed Vanity
Fair in a tweet the magazine
subscriptions soared a hundred fold a
single day company record so Trump may
actually save America's journalism
industry
Trump has been tweeting a range of
insults at Kim jung-un
seemingly bring in the US and North
Korea closer to a nuclear conflict even
the Pope has warned about the danger of
a nuclear war but this whole debacle has
had its positive side effect it has
brought North and South Korea closer
together turns out the two enemy nations
are suddenly talking again and not just
that they're discussing sending a joint
women's ice hockey team to the Winter
Olympics and having athletes from both
countries March together
Jemmy opening of course Trump has taken
credit for this development
if I weren't involved they wouldn't be
talking about Olympics like that that
only leaves one problem the continuing
animosity between the u.s. and North
Korea ours is not a [ __ ] old country
neither is high tea Trump seems to take
pride in insulting people but sometimes
that has a positive side effect to
remember Trump's [ __ ] countries
comment that was referring to countries
like Haiti El Salvador and unspecified
African nations his common was widely
condemned as racist and divisive but the
good news is it actually brought people
from these countries together to speak
up and show pride on social media
there's not an eyeing that as the
president of the United States Donald
Trump has a lot of power over the
political agenda but here's the silver
lining in the past year millions of
people have snapped into action
so despite Trump or maybe because of him
people have already created real change
what's in store for the rest of his term